Hablemos un poco sobre los sólidos iónicos que,
como pueden imaginar, son sólidos formados por
iones, entonces pensemos un poco sobre estos
iones. Por ejemplo, podríamos ver aquí a los
elementos del grupo 1, especialmente al litio,
sodio o potasio; y en muchos otros videos hemos
hablado sobre estos elementos que no desean
tanto conservar su electrón más externo,
porque sólo tienen 1 electrón en su capa exterior,
y es bastante fácil para ellos perderlo para
llegar a una configuración de gas noble y así
tener una capa exterior completa. Entonces,
a estos personajes les gusta perder 1 electrón;
a los elementos del grupo 2 les gusta perder 2
electrones. Mientras que al otro lado de la tabla
periódica, si vemos los halógenos aquí, les falta
sólo 1 electrón para tener una configuración de
electrones de gas noble, de tener una capa externa
completa. A ellos realmente les gusta hacerse
de electrones. Podemos observar elementos como
el oxígeno y el azufre a los que les gusta,
si pueden, tomar 2 electrones. Entonces,
¿qué creen que sucede si tenemos algunos metales
de este extremo izquierdo mezclados con algunos
no metales del extremo derecho? Bueno, pueden
imaginar que habría una reacción. Por ejemplo, si
mezclamos sodio con cloro, los sodios pueden ceder
1 electrón a los cloros, en cuyo caso tendremos
cationes sodio, iones cargados positivamente;
y si los cloros ahora toman esos electrones
se convierten en aniones cloruro. Y, ahora, si
tenemos un montón de iones positivos alrededor de
un montón de iones negativos, ¿qué creen que va a
suceder? Se sentirán atraídos entre sí y formarán
una estructura reticular como esta. Me gusta usar
cloruro de sodio porque este es probablemente el
ejemplo que más encontramos en nuestra vida, pues
es la sal de mesa. Si lo probáramos sabría salado,
pero hay muchos otros sólidos iónicos, muchos de
ellos en realidad se clasificarían como sal en
general: podríamos tener un cloruro de potasio,
podríamos tener un fluoruro de sodio, podríamos
tener, por ejemplo, un óxido de magnesio. ¿Qué
está pasando ahí? Bueno, en esta situación cada
magnesio puede perder 2 electrones, por lo que
se convierten en 1 ion con carga positiva de 2,
y cada uno de los oxígenos ganaría 2 electrones,
por lo que queda como anión con una carga negativa
de 2. Y estos personajes una vez más se atraerán
entre sí y formarán un sólido iónico en una
estructura reticular regular como esta. Así que
pensemos un poco sobre sus propiedades. Antes
que nada, pensemos en los puntos de fusión.
En estos sólidos, la atracción electrostática
entre estos iones es fuerte, por lo que tienden a
tener puntos de fusión altos. Y si comparamos los
puntos de fusión entre sólidos iónicos entonces,
por ejemplo, si quisiéramos comparar el punto de
fusión del cloruro de sodio con el punto de fusión
del óxido de magnesio, ¿cuál creen que tendrá un
punto de fusión más alto? Pausen este video y
piensen en ello. Bueno, como pueden imaginar,
la atracción electrostática dependerá de dos
cosas: la magnitud de la carga y el radio de
los átomos que forman esta estructura reticular.
Y la magnitud de la carga aquí es clara: aquí hay
una carga +2 atraída por una carga negativa de 2,
por lo que tiene una atracción electrostática más
fuerte y tendrá un punto de fusión más alto, el
punto de fusión del óxido de magnesio 2,825°C,
mientras que el punto de fusión de la sal
de mesa o el cloruro de sodio es de 801°C.
También podríamos intentar comparar el cloruro de
sodio con algo como el fluoruro de sodio. ¿Cuál
creen que tendrá un punto de fusión más alto, el
cloruro de sodio o el fluoruro de sodio? Bueno,
los flúor son más pequeños que los cloros, y
cada uno de ellos gana 1 electrón, entonces
el anión fluoruro seguirá siendo razonablemente
más pequeño que el anión cloruro. Cuando tenemos
iones constituyentes más pequeños, la atracción
electrostática es realmente más fuerte. Recuerden
que en la Ley de Coulomb vemos que cuanto más
cercanas son dos cargas entre sí más fuerte es
la fuerza atractiva o repulsiva, y si son cargas
opuestas será una fuerza atractiva. Entonces,
el fluoruro de sodio tiene un punto de fusión
más alto que el cloruro de sodio por un poco,
en realidad resulta que el punto de fusión del
fluoruro de sodio es de 996°C. Pero si comparamos
éstos tres, el punto de fusión más alto lo tiene
el óxido de magnesio, seguido del fluoruro de
sodio, seguido del cloruro de sodio. Entonces,
la carga es lo que realmente domina aquí. Ahora,
la siguiente pregunta que tal vez se hagan es,
bueno, podemos imaginar que estos sólidos son
realmente duros, pero ¿qué pasaría si tratáramos
de romperlos? Se doblarán como muchos de los
metales que conocemos, y lo estudiaremos en otros
videos. ¿O pasará algo más? Y para entender eso,
déjenme dibujar una representación bidimensional
de esto. Así que voy a dibujar el cloro,
o debería decir los aniones cloruro. Esta es
sólo una versión bidimensional de esta retícula,
obviamente no está dibujada a escala. Permítanme
dibujar los sodios, cationes sodio. Como pueden
ver, los positivos se sienten atraídos por los
negativos, por eso están uno al lado del otro,
los negativos no están uno al lado del otro
porque se repelen entre sí, los positivos
no están uno al lado del otro. ¿Pero qué pasaría
si tratara de hacerlo o si presionara muy fuerte
este lado hacia abajo y presionara muy fuerte
este lado hacia arriba? ¿Qué pasaría si presiono
lo suficiente como para que este lado comience a
ceder? ¿Comienza a ceder, se doblaría o qué creen
que va a pasar cuando llegue por aquí? Bueno,
cuando llegue a ese punto, de repente no sólo
habré roto la retícula, sino que los negativos
estarán al lado de los negativos y los positivos
estarán al lado de los positivos, por lo que no se
doblará y será maleable como muchos de los metales
que hemos visto, simplemente se romperá, por lo
que, aunque sea duro, será quebradizo. Ahora,
la última pregunta que abordaremos en este video
es: ¿qué tan bien conducen la electricidad los
sólidos iónicos? Pausen el video y piensen en eso.
Bueno, para conducir electricidad los electrones o
la carga generalmente tiene que poder moverse
y cuando están en su forma sólida como esta,
aunque tengan estos iones, no se moverán, por
lo que los sólidos iónicos en su forma sólida no
son buenos para conducir electricidad, pueden ser
buenos para conducir electricidad si se disuelven
en una solución. Por ejemplo, si tuviéramos
que disolver esta sal en agua, ahora los iones
podrían moverse y serían buenos para conducir
electricidad; o si tuviéramos que calentar este
cloruro de sodio a más de 801°C y se convirtiera
en un líquido, entonces una vez más los iones
podrían moverse y conducir electricidad. Tomen
todo lo que digo con un grano de sal. Lo siento,
no sé, no pude evitarlo, pero espero que ahora
sepan un poco más sobre los sólidos iónicos.